WE ARE CAREFULLY AND SLOWLY
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
COMES TO US.
>> Dana: FOLLOWING IT CLOSELY
INDEED.
CDC A POSITIVE ON THE PANDEMIC
IN FEWER DEATHS IN THE COMING
WEEKS.
THE AGENCY SAYS IT COULD FALL TO
3200 BY APRIL 10TH.
DR. MARTY MAKARY, JOHN HOPKINS
SCHOOL OF POLICY.
SO I’M SORRY, ABOUT A MONTH AGO
THAT YOU WROTE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP ED AND
GOT A BUNCH OF CRITICISM.
DO YOU FEEL A LITTLE VINDICATION
THIS MORNING?
>> LOOK, I’M NOT LOOKING TO WIN
AN ARGUMENT.
I DON’T THINK THOSE PEOPLE WILL
APOLOGIZE WHEN THEY SHOW IT IS
CORRECT.
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE MODELS THAT
PREDICT THINGS FAR WORSE THAN
REALITY.
IF YOU PREDICT AND ACCURATE
MODEL.
BUT THE PROJECTION GAVE PEOPLE A
FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY.
I THINK IT ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED
PEOPLE TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO UNTIL WE GET TO THAT POINT
BECAUSE HOPE IS ON THE WAY.
I THINK THE NUMBERS ARE POINTING
THAT WAY.
>> Dana: SO THE NUMBERS COME
AT THE KAY’S IS DROPPING, SEVEN
DAY MOVING AVERAGE FROM
JANUARY 21 WITH 250,000 AND
MARCHED DOWN TO 50,000.
SO YOU THINK IT HAS SOME TO DO
WITH HERD IMMUNITY AND VACCINES.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN?
>> FIRST OF ALL, HERD IMMUNITY
IS SIGNIFICANTLY SLOWING.
IT’S NOT A HARD CUT OFF BUT IT’S
BEEN KICKING IN.
WE ALREADY HAVE HERD IMMUNITY
FOR THE NATION’S 23 MILLION
HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
MOST OF THEM VACCINATED AND SOME
OTHERS WHO HAVEN’T ALREADY HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY FROM PRIOR
INFECTION.
WE ARE A WEEK OR TWO AWAY FROM
HERD IMMUNITY IN THE NURSING
HOMES.
CASES ARE DOWN 98%.
TEN STATES HAVE HAD DAYS WITH
ZERO DEATHS.
WHAT DO YOU CALL THAT?
I CALLED AT HERD IMMUNITY.
WE WILL SEE HERD IMMUNITY ACROSS
THE STREET IN APRIL AND MAY.
THAT IS PART OF THE DIFFERENCE
IN VACCINATION RATES.
BUT WE ARE SEEING SOME REALLY
GOOD NEWS.
I DON’T THINK WE WILL EXTINGUISH
THIS FIRE AS I WROTE IN THAT
PIECE.
WE WILL SEE CASES LINGER ABOUT
THE DEBATE IS "WHO ARE THOSE
PEOPLE?"
AND THOSE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
ASYMPTOMATIC AND MILD DISEASE.
THEY COULD LINGER THROUGH MAY
AND EARLY JUNE.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK, IS
AT THE NEXT BIG ARGUMENT OR WHAT
IS THE NEXT BIG ARGUMENT?
>> THERE WAS AN ARTICLE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT
CONSERVATIVES UNDERSTATE THE
RISK.
DEMOCRATS EXAGGERATE THE RISK.
AND THEY DID A SURVEY SHOWING
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE ABOUT 20% OF
COVID PATIENTS ARE HOSPITALIZED.
NOT TRUE, ABOUT 1%.
SO WHAT YOU WILL SEE IS THIS
ARGUMENT WHEN THEY ARE CASES IN
MAY, SOME WITH THE PANDEMIC TO
KEEP GOING IT WILL SAY THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH RISK
AND IT CAN SURGE AGAIN.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THOSE ARE
YOUNG, ASYMPTOMATIC CASES AND
THEY WILL NOT SEARCH BECAUSE
FEWER, SUSCEPTIBLE PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
THERE WAS A LOT OF VACCINATED
NATURAL IMMUNITY.
>> Dana: YOU DEMAND PEOPLE
DELAY THEIR SECOND DOSE?
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
WE CAN SAVE MORE LIVES IF PEOPLE
DELAYED THE SECOND DOSE.